[Music]  here in Detroit a city of war on the  city's west side at 150 block area is  off-limits to everybody US army  paratroopers National Guardsmen state  and local police are continuing the  fight against a handful of snipers hello  Oh everything is fine no trouble here  I'll sleep when they stop riding a  fellas be I'm going that grocery store  across the street I've come bearing  gifts thank you yeah sugar  don't push your bed it's a war zone out  there they're destroying the city oh hey  y'all seeing this Hey look we're not so  far from the house let's just go to it  so all this goes over when the black is  almost like having a gun pointed at your  face it's like this hey boy what you  doing on my street  [Music]  hey police how siren  let's not be stupid in this situation  you need to tell me where the gun is I  got all night people tell me exactly  what is going on here  I need you to survive  you think we're bluffin  you  you